[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien guten Abend die
Sport-Highlights später mit dir Sven so
sieht's aus schön guten Abend auch von
mir das sind heute unsere Themen
illegale Einwanderung und die Suche nach
Lösungen Innenministerin Feser erweckt
jetzt doch stationäre Kontrollen an den
Grenzen zu Polen und Tschechien CDU-Chef
März will ein gemeinsames Vorgehen in
der flüchtlingskrise
fast alle für Markus Söder die CSU zeigt
vor den Wahlen in Bayern Geschlossenheit
und bestätigt Parteichef Söder mit
persönlichem Rekord-Ergebnis im Amt
und mehr Lehrer mehr Kitaplätze mehr
Geld in vielen Städten demonstrieren
tausende für bessere Bildung in
Deutschland
[Musik]
es ist ordentlich Druck auf dem Kessel
in der Flüchtlingspolitik seit Tagen
trommelt die Union fordert den Zuzug von
Migranten zu begrenzen CDU-Chef März
poltert heute weiter bot dem Kanzler
Zusammenarbeit an und empfiehlt sogar
den Rausschmiss der Grünen aus der Ampel
sollte sich die Politik nicht ändern
zuvor hatte Innenministerin Fräser
verstärkte Grenzkontrollen an den
Übergängen zu Polen und Tschechien ins
Spiel gebracht stichpunktartig gibt es
sie schon Britta Spiekermann
die Stadt Forst in der Lausitz ein
Hotspot für schleuserkriminalität ganz
im Osten Deutschlands Grenzgebiet zu
Polen und Tschechien ein Bewohner gab
den Hinweis ihm war eine Gruppe
aufgefallen 16 Flüchtlinge werden in
einer Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung gebracht
die Schleuser sind längste über alle
Berge was die Bundespolizei darf und was
nicht ist häufig unklar
der Druck wird größer stolz auf eine
spd-wahlkampfveranstaltung in Nürnberg
ja zum Grundrecht auf Asyl ja zu mehr
Abschiebungen und jahrzehn
möglicherweise mehr Maßnahmen an Grenzen
wie etwa die Grenzkontrollen zu Schweiz
er Aktion hat gewirkt
wir diskutieren das mit Tschechien wie
das geht vielleicht so wie bei der
Schweiz bin ich später beim Wahlkampf
mit bundesinnenministerin Faeser sie
hatte gestern eine Kehrtwende vollzogen
kein Fernsehinterview aber Presse
Schlagzeilen feza für Grenzkontrollen zu
Polen und Tschechien solche zusätzlichen
Kontrollen müssen mit der Überwachung
des gesamten Grenzgebiets durch die
Schleierfahndung gut zusammengreifen
Grenzkontrollen würden das Problem nicht
lösen aber helfen sagt Friedrich Merz
heute zu Gast beim CSU-Parteitag März
bietet Kanzler Scholz Zusammenarbeit an
lassen Sie uns das zusammen machen und
wenn sie es mit dem grünen nicht
hinbekommen dann werfen Sie sie raus
dann machen wir es mit ihnen aber wir
müssen dieses Problem lösen liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde ich kann nur für
uns als grüne plädieren ein
Maßnahmepaket zu machen zu bündeln
stationäre Grenzkontrollen können ein
Punkt sein wichtig ist dass wir einen
europäischen verteilmechanismus haben
Vizekanzler Harbig sagt seine Partei sei
so pragmatischen Lösungen bereit man
müsste die Realität annehmen eine
Obergrenze lehnt er ab die Bundespolizei
wartet auf klare Regelungen in der
Lausitz führt sie schon vermehrt
Kontrollen durch noch bewegen sich die
Beamten in einer rechtlichen Grauzone
die für bayerische Verhältnisse in den
Umfragen schwächelnde CSU hat sich heute
auf ihrem Parteitag für die Landtagswahl
in zwei Wochen eingestimmt dabei gab es
auch ordentliche Rückenwind für den
Spitzenkandidaten und
Ministerpräsidenten Söder mit
rekorddergebnis wurde er als Parteichef
bestätigt Jutta sonnwald
Markus Söder muss in gut zwei Wochen
liefern dann will die CSU die Wahl
gewinnen die Delegierten schicken ihn
mit dem erhofften Zuspruch ins Rennen
mehr als 96% haben ihn als CSU-Chef
wiedergewählt für ihn ein
rekorddergebnis ich danke euch für
dieses tolle Ergebnis ist echt großartig
herzlichen Dank wirklich danke schön
diesen Rückenwind brauchen Markus Söder
und seine CSU nach den miserablen
Umfrageergebnissen der letzten Wochen
den Freien Wählern die mit Hubert
Aiwanger an der Spitze trotz
flugplatzaffäre zugelegt haben rät er zu
mir die Mut unser Koalitionspartner
fordert mehr macht
der Koalitionspartner fordert schon von
vornherein das
Landwirtschaftsministerium
ich bin meine ganz sicher ob dem einen
oder anderen Umfragen etwas zu Kopf
gestiegen sind das Dilemma für Markus
Söder und seine Christ sozialen
einerseits sind sie auf die Freien
Wähler angewiesen andererseits wird der
Koalitionspartner zum politischen
Konkurrenten also natürlich streben wir
da schon noch einen starken Ergebnis für
die CSU in erster Linie also gewisser
Weise ich habe mir schon dass wir noch
ein paar Prozente die Freien Wähler auch
abgehauen können und wenn die CSU ihre
40% erreicht hat jetzt aus meiner Sicht
das Ziel ist dass wir erreichen sollten
dann ist alles gut und dann können die
freiwiller machen was sie wollen
rückendeckung bekommt Söder von seinem
Gast Friedrich Merz beide sagen der AFD
den Kampf an beide teilen gegen die
Ampel in Berlin aus
und dieser Ampel meine Damen und Herren
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde hat den
Tiefpunkt jedenfalls den vorläufigen
Tiefpunkt ihres Ansehens in der
Bevölkerung erreicht Markus Söder hat
seine CSU kämpferisch auf den
entscheidenden Schluss Sport im
Wahlkampf eingefroren seine Partei
zumindest steht demonstrativ hinter ihm
dann wollen wir doch mal nachfragen bei
Stefan in München Stefan wie und womit
will Parteichef Söder bis zu den Wahlen
in zwei Wochen Punkten
ja Markus Söder hat es heute hier beim
Tal Parteitag mit drei Botschaften
versucht das erste ist die Botschaft von
der maximalen Mobilisierung die jetzt im
endspur 2 Wochen vor der Wahl noch nötig
ist um das Ruder noch rumzureißen
angesichts der eher durchwachsenden
Umfragen das Thema Migration soll dazu
beitragen das ist die zweite Botschaft
eigentlich hatte sich die CSU fest
vorgenommen das Thema nicht zum
Wahlkampf Thema zu machen aber der Druck
aus den Kommunen ist dann doch zu groß
geworden und Markus Söder versucht es
jetzt mit einer Tonlage die das Thema
ansprechen aber nicht ins
rechtspopulistische abdriften lassen
soll und die dritte Botschaft ist ein
neues erwartungsmanagement was wir heute
erlebt haben Markus Söder der Parteichef
gibt keine zielmage mehr vor nicht mal
das Ergebnis vom letzten Mal ist das
mindestens Ziel sondern es gehen nur
darum weiter zu regieren das ist ein
erwartungsmanagement nach unten mit
seiner Wiederwahl und den 96% hat sich
Markus Söder den maximalen Rückhalt der
Partei heute hier gesichert wie viel das
wert ist wird man nach der Wahl am 8
Oktober sehen Stefan habe vielen Dank
nach München
die Ukraine hat nach russischen Angaben
wieder die annektierte Halbinsel Krim
attackiert in der Stadt Sebastopol soll
es Explosionen gegeben haben der
ukrainische Präsident selensky hat
seinen Besuch in Kanada inzwischen
beendet nach beiden sagte auch
Premierminister trudeaux weitere
Militärhilfen zu 50 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
im Wert von knapp einer halben Milliarde
Euro
schauen wir auf China dass ihr als
Wirtschaftsmotor der Welt gilt das Land
hat aber schwere Probleme besonders die
Immobilienbranche leidet seit der
corona-krise mit den strengen lockdowns
stocken viele Bauvorhaben die Preise
sinken die Folge immer mehr
Immobilienfirmen geraten in
Zahlungsschwierigkeiten schätzungen zu
Folge stehen bis zu 100 Millionen
Wohnungen leer aus China berichtet
Elisabeth Schmidt
es sieht aus wie in einer Geisterstadt
gut 20 Stockwerke sind diese betongeräte
hoch alle Wohnungen längst verkauft alle
unfertig manche Eigentümer warten seit
drei Jahren auf die Fertigstellung Wut
und Verzweiflung in den sozialen Medien
wir haben keine Möglichkeit uns zu
beschweren Unkraut auf der Baustelle
Wasser bis zum Knies seit einem Jahr
Stillstand die baurine dieses Mannes
steht in Chiang Hong wir fahren dorthin
eine gute Autostunde von Peking entfernt
die Kräne stehen still Bauschutt soweit
das Auge reicht wir fragen nach
in den letzten zwei Jahren hat der Hua
die Immobilienfirma hier wegen der
schlechten Wirtschaft Probleme Huas ja
und der größte Immobilienkonzern
evergrounds sind fast pleite das
verursacht viele Bau Ruinen
und dem Staat ein großes Problem denn
der Immobiliensektor ist in China für
ein Viertel der Wirtschaftskraft
verantwortlich die gesamtauswirkungen
sind noch gar nicht abzusehen
in der vergangenen Jahren eigentlich
fast immer ein
Wachstumsmotor vielleicht sogar der
große Wachstumsmotor in der
Weltwirtschaft das ist erstmal ein wenig
vorüber das merken vor allen Dingen die
Rohstofflieferanten und auch unsere
Industrie wird es merken dass in China
nicht mehr so viel eingekauft wird wie
gewohnt
Chinas Staatsführung schaut bislang zu
Spekulationsgeschäfte werden es eine
Erfindung des westlichen Kapitalismus
abgelehnt einen gefährliches Spiel für
China sozialen Frieden und für die
Weltwirtschaft
Schüler Lehrer Eltern ganze Familien
sind heute in vielen deutschen Städten
auf die Straße gegangen und haben nichts
weniger als eine Wende in der Bildung
gefordert konkret Schluss mit dem
Lehrermangel Schulen und Kitas
renovieren und besser ausstatten weil
all das kostet fordern die Demonstranten
und auch der Deutsche Gewerkschaftsbund
dafür mindestens 100 Milliarden Euro aus
Berlin Stefanie gagusch
es geht um ihre Zukunft und die
Deutschlands tausende kamen zum
bundesweiten Bildungsprotest wer etwa
hier in Berlin dabei auch viele Kinder
die ihr Recht auf lernen einforderten
also ich finde es blöd ist sehr viel
Unterricht auffällt weil so viele so
wenig Lehrer sind ich möchte auch
Unterricht haben und nicht nur
zu Hause sitzen oder in die Notbetreuung
gehen in allen 16 Bundesländern gab es
Proteste demonstrierte ein breites
Bündnis für eine Zeitenwende auch in der
Bildung die Organisatoren sehen die
Bundesregierung mit in der Verantwortung
wir wollen wirklich ein anderes System
in Kita und Schule haben dazu braucht es
mehr Personal wir fordert eine
Ausbildung für Lehrkräfte und Erzieherin
und auf jeden Fall mehr Geld ein
Sondervermögen von 100 Milliarden Euro
Bildung gehe jeden an und die Probleme
in der Schule seien die Probleme aller
Menschen in Deutschland
weil uns fehlen jetzt schon massenhaft
an Arbeitskräften und es verlassen immer
noch viel zu viele Jugendliche 50 6000
jährlich die Schulen ohne Abschluss und
die Menschen verlieren wir dann ist das
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Riesenproblem
was da auf uns zukommt Schule Kitas in
der Krise dabei ist Bildung ein
Menschenrecht
Proteste auch auf Rügen dort gingen
hunderte gegen das lng-projekt auf die
Straße bisher sind ja alle Klagen
dagegen gescheitert die Gegner
befürchten Auswirkungen auf Umwelt und
Tourismus
gebaut wird im Nordosten von Rügen im
Hafen von Mukran entsteht das
eigentliche flüssig-erdgast Terminal
Teil des Projektes ist aber auch eine
Pipeline zwischen Mukran und Lubmin eine
Stadt fällt und Bernd Mosebach dazu
Umweltaktivisten sind auf das
Hafengelände von Mukran auf Rügen
vorgedrungen die Polizei muss die
Blockade auflösen die Demonstranten
wollen verhindern dass hier ein Terminal
für verflüssigtes Erdgas entsteht sie
sind gegen Energie aus fossilen
Brennstoffen das ist vielfach schädlich
als CO2 das heißt diese Aussage ist Gas
eine saubere Brückentechnologie es ist
einfach eine Lüge die Bundesregierung
hält das Projekt für alternativlos am
Hafen wo Kran sollen künftig Tanker LNG
andern und über eine derzeit im Bau
befindliche Pipeline das Gas nach Lubmin
bringen hier soll es Anfang 2024 ins
Netz eingespeist werden auf Rügen regt
sich seit Monaten heftiger Widerstand es
ist nicht nachgewiesen dass es ein
Bedarf dafür gibt und es ist auch nicht
notwendig Rügen ist eine Insel braucht
eine Insel Lösung und wir sind nicht
diejenigen die andere hier versorgen
sollen die lng-gegner der Insel
befürchten vor allem Einbußen der
Tourismusbranche der Bürgermeister von
Sassnitz Leon kreusche hält dagegen der
Hafen Mukran gehört größtenteils seiner
Gemeinde für ihn ein Wirtschaftsfaktor
wir waren nie der touristische Standort
sondern waren immer im Prinzip eine
Industrie- und Gewerbestandort durch
Fischindustrie durch andere Sachen das
gibt es in der Form nicht mehr also
müssen wir so umorientieren und wir
haben den Standort mit Kran den gilt es
zu entwickeln mehrere Klagen gegen das
Projekt sind bisher abgewiesen worden
weitere sind angekündigt der Protest auf
Rügen reist nicht ab
jetzt zu Protesten ganz anderer Art bei
Eritrea Veranstaltungen in Deutschland
kam es zuletzt vermehrt zu gewaltsamen
Ausschreitungen
Befürworter und Gegner des eritreischen
Regimes gerieten aneinander
Eritrea liegt im Nordosten Afrikas seit
seiner Unabhängigkeit vor 30 Jahren ist
das Land eine Diktatur Oppositionelle
sind brutalen Repressionen ausgesetzt in
Deutschland leben etwa 80.000 Eritrea so
viele wie in keinem anderen europäischen
Staat über den Konflikt zwischen regime-
knapp 230 vorwiegend junge Männer Gegner
der Regierung in Eritrea protestieren im
vergangenen Samstag in Stuttgart
bewaffnet mit Metallstangen und
Holzlatten schlagen sie auf andere
Eritrea ein sie werfen ihn Nähe zur
diktatorischen Regierung des
afrikanischen Landes vor so wie hier
entlädt sich momentan der Konflikt
zwischen regime-anhängern und Gegnern
weltweit
Eritrea die vor 30 Jahren geflüchtet
sind haften einem Eritrea an oder haben
die Nostalgie an ein Eritrea das vor 30
Jahren vielleicht auch 20 oder 25 Jahren
bestand die Entwicklung im Land hat eine
andere Wendung genommen diejenigen die
nun geflüchtet sind sind nicht Teil der
Befreiungsbewegung sind Perspektive lose
junge Menschen die meisten von ihnen
sind anerkannte Asylbewerber die vor dem
Militärdienst des eritreischen Diktators
Isaias nach Europa geflüchtet sind
dessen Arm reicht sogar bis ins Exil
erzählt Afrika konfliktexperte Martin
Plaut
die verlangen zum Beispiel dass jeder
Eritrea eine 2-prozentige Steuer an die
Regierung in Asmara abführt und dann
verlangen sie auch noch dass du das
Regime unterstützt und dass du auf die
Straße gehst und wir sie demonstrierst
sie haben auch eine Reihe von Ländern
über die Übersetzungsdienste der
Regierung des Gastlandes infiltriert
all das wollen die Jüngeren Eritrea
nicht mehr hinnehmen experten befürchten
dass es deshalb weiter zu Gewaltexzessen
kommen wird
und noch ein Blick nach Schweden und
zwar in die Nähe von Göteborg im Westen
des Landes dort sind über 100 Meter
einer Schnellstraße nach einem Erdrutsch
weggebrochen drei Menschen wurden
verletzt als ihre Autos über die Kante
der zerstörten Straße stürzten der
Auslöser für den Erdrutsch ist noch
unklar die Polizei untersucht an den
möglichen Zusammenhang mit Spreng
Arbeiten in der Gegend
jetzt der Sport mit Sven Voß und du
startest mit fußballtrend ja und zwar
mit dem fünften Bundesliga-Spieltag an
dem die Bayern zumindest vorübergehend
auf Platz 1 springen der Heimsieg gegen
Bochum war nie gefährdet drei Tore
erzielte der überragende Harry Kane am
Ende gewinnt der deutsche Meister mit
7:0 Borussia Dortmund schlägt den VfL
Wolfsburg mit 1:0 nach dem Champions
League die Bühl am Mittwoch verliert
Union Berlin zu Hause gegen Hoffenheim
mit Null zu zwei Heimniederlage auch für
Gladbach gegen Leipzig ein Treffer von
Timo Werner Recht den Sachsen Augsburg
Dritter Spiel gegen Mainz und gewinnt
mit 2:1 bereits gestern besiegte der VfB
Stuttgart Aufsteiger Darmstadt mit drei
zu eins das Abendspiel bestreiten Bremen
und Köln morgen noch zwei Spiele in der
Tabelle stehen die Bayern vorübergehend
ganz oben Leverkusen kann sich morgen
wieder in die Spitze schieben auf zwei
und drei Stuttgart und Leipzig Dortmund
auf fünf in der zweiten Tabellenhälfte
klettert Augsburg auf Platz 11 Darmstadt
und Mainz auf den Abstiegsplätzen
alles zur Bundesliga im Aktuellen
Sportstudio Hoffenheim nur ein Punkt
hinter den Bayern das wird unseren Gast
freuen Sportchef Alexander Rosen ist ab
23 Uhr bei uns
für die deutschen Volleyball-Frauen ist
die Olympia-Qualifikation vorerst in
Ferne gerückt in weite Ferne gegen Polen
spielte das deutsche die deutsche
Auswahl stark verlor aber nach fünf und
kämpften Sätzen mit zwei zu drei nur die
beiden besten der Quali Gruppe dürfen in
Paris starten Deutschland liegt aktuell
hinter den USA Italien und Polen auf
Platz 4
und auch für die deutschen Fußballfrauen
wird es schwierig mit dem Olympia-Ticket
für Paris denn im ersten nations League
Spiel musste die DFB-Auswahl eine
bittere Niederlage hinnehmen bei 0:2
gegen Dänemark zeigte sich die deutsche
Elf wenig verbessert beide gegen Tore
erzielte Amalie wonskat am Dienstag
geht's gegen Island nur der Sieger der
nations League Gruppe hat weiter Chancen
auf Olympia
und das war's fast vom Sport wir haben
aber noch Formel 1 und zwar Formel 1
Weltmeister Max Verstappen ist nicht zu
stoppen in der Qualifikation zum Großen
Preis von Japan war der 25-Jährige der
schnellste und startet morgen als erster
ins Rennen
Wachs Verstappen ist nicht nur zurück in
der Erfolgsspur sondern er dominiert die
Konkurrenz wieder nach Belieben seine
beste Runde in Suzuka mehr als eine
halbe Sekunde schneller als die seines
Nächsten Verfolgers und das ist
überraschend der Australier Oskar
piastri im Mercedes befeuerten McLaren
dessen Teamkollege London Norris auf
Platz 3 Singapur Sieger Carlos science
nur sechster im Ferrari dahinter die
Werks Mercedes mit Hamilton und Russell
Nico Hülkenberg bisher ohne Punkte in
dieser Saison startet von Rang 18 aus
ins Rennen am Sonntagmorgen
jetzt aber das war der Samstag Sport
danke dir wenn beim Wetter da wird
herbstlich freundlich dazu gleich mehr
von östant herrling das heute journal
gibt es heute um 22:45 Uhr mit Dunja
Hayali schönen Abend schönen Dank und
bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter zum heutigen
Herbstbeginn dehnt sich ein Hoch aus und
beruhigt das Wetter und zwar kommt das
vom Südwesten her und schiebt die Tiefs
allmählich ostwärts und so wird es
deutlich sonniger in den nächsten Tagen
schauen wir in die Nacht und da gibt es
noch ganz im Norden Regen und ganz im
Süden ansonsten zeigen sich häufig die
Sterne und den Gewässernähe bildet sich
Nebel das bei tiefsten Temperaturen von
3 Grad im Süden hier wird schon deutlich
spürbar kälter und auch im Westen in der
Eifel drei Grad an der Nordsee und an
der Ostsee ist es deutlich milder mit 12
Grad hier wärmt das mehr nach morgen
dann in der Mitte kompaktere Wolken die
lösen sich dann im Tagesverlauf auf und
dann gibt es so viel Sonnenschein wie im
Westen oder im Südwesten Deutschlands
bei höchsten Temperaturen von 22 Grad am
Oberrhein und 16 Grad an den Alpen aber
häufig sind die Temperaturen um die 20
Grad angesiedelt die nächsten Tage
sondern Teile nehmen zu nach Nebel
Auflösung Montag bei 18 bis 24 Grad
Dienstag bis 27 Grad und Mittwoch bis 28
Grad damit ein schöner Abend